♪♪
>>> Florida governor Ron
Desantis is now providing the
clearest indication yet of where
he stands on a major foreign
policy issue.
Desantis telling Fox News's
tucker Carlson he disagrees
where most in his party are in
Ukraine, putting it this way.
Saying, quote, while the U.S.
Has many vital national
interests, skurg our borders,
addressing the crisis of
readiness with our military,
achieving energy security and
Independence and checking the
economic cultural military power
of the Chinese communist party,
becoming involved in a
territorial dispute with Russia
and Ukraine is not one of them.
Desantis has not announced he's
running with.
Put that in context with what
Desantis said back in 2015.
This was after Russia illegally
annexed crimea.
He was then a congressman and
this is what he said at the
time.
We in the congress have been
urging the president, referring
to president Obama, to provide
arms to Ukraine.
They want to fight their good
fight.
They're not asking us to fight
it for them.
And the president has
steadfastly refused.
I think that's a mistake.
>> And governor Ron Desantis,
former president trump's most
frequent target on the campaign
trail in Iowa.
So CNN's Kristen Holmes live now
in Davenport with more on this.
Kristen, good morning to you.
How did trump's first Iowa stop
go, full of jokes, I'm sure.
>> Reporter: Good morning, don.
Well, this was really the first
time we heard him go after
Desantis by name in a speech
since he announced his candidacy
for president.
Usually he saves that for his
social media page or for these
one on one interviews.
And I will say that while it was
a very enthusiastic night, the
response to those criticisms of
the Florida governor was a
little bit lukewarm.
It was clear from people that we
talked to that while they like
trump and maybe they like trump
better, they still like Florida
governor Ron Desantis.
But one thing was very clear in
the last two days we spent here.
We talked to people.
We saw the crowd last night.
It was a packed house for Donald
Trump.
And, of course, those CNN poll
numbers, Donald Trump is still a
huge force in the Republican
party.
>> Reporter: Former president
Donald Trump taking aim at
Florida governor Ron Desantis in
Iowa.
>> Ron desantus.
>> Reporter: During his first
trip to the crucial early state
since announcing his third white
house bid.
>> Ron was a disciple of Paul
Ryan.
Who is a rhino loser who
currently is destroying fox and
would constantly vote against
entitlements.
>> Reporter: At this early
stage, Desantis is widely seen
as the former president's chief
rival for the GOP nomination.
>> Ron Desantis strongly opposed
ethanal.
Do you know that?
And we don't even know if he's
running.
But I might as well tell you, if
he's not rung, I will say he was
fine on ethanal.
>> Reporter: The Florida
governor has yet to announce a
presidential run.
Earlier in the evening, trump
setting his sights on another
potential 2024 hopeful.
His former running mate, while
seeking to deflect blame for the
violent attack on the capitol on
January 6th.
Telling "The Washington post"
that Mike pence was at least in
part to blame for the events
that day.
Saying, quote, had he sent the
votes back to the legislatures,
they wouldn't have had a problem
with January 6th.
So in many ways, you can blame
him for January 6th.
Trump's comments in response to
the former vice president
delivering his sharpest rebuke
yet of his former boss in a
private speech during an annual
dinner in Washington, pence
telling attendees, quote, I know
that history will hold Donald
Trump accountable for January
6th.
Trump becoming the latest 2024
Republican hopeful to visit
Iowa.
>> The agricultural industry
should be treated just like the
manufacturing industry.
>> We said we are going to go on
offense.
I'm going to find issues.
>> Reporter: As the 2024 GOP
field begins to take shape.
A new CNN poll showing that the
former president still remains a
leading figure in the party.
40% of Republicans and
republican-leaning independents
said they would most likely back
trump for the GOP nomination
when given a list of nine
potential candidates.
Compared to the 36% who chose
Florida governor Ron Desantis.
The only two to reach double
digits.
With former vice president pence
and former U.N. Ambassador Nikki
Haley at 6% each.
>> And don, of course it is
important to note that this is
still very early.
Obviously the former vice
president as well as the Florida
governor have not even announced
that they are going to be
running for president.
Even though, of course, that is
anticipated.
But this is expected to be a
very crowded GOP field.
And it's expected to be a very
busy next year and a half.
Don?
>> Right on that, Kristen.
Yet here we are covering them.
Thank you so much.
I wonder if we should make --
unless they declare, should we
not talk about them as if they
are running?
You know what I'm saying?
Until you declare --
>> 36% of people in that poll
want --
>> We could have done that last
year or the year before.
>> Kind of reminds me of what
trump said last night.
He was saying that Desantis is
bad on ethanal.
He said, but unless he doesn't
run for president I'll say he's
good on ethanal.
>> We got a fourth guest to the
table.
>> Hi.
He is CNN political analyst and
national politics reporter for
"The New York Times" as well.
Good morning to you.
>> Good morning.
I also loved that trump line on
Desantis.
Just showing how transactional
his politics really is.
>> So I said what are you hot
on?
>> I think that this
presidential race is really
turning up to another level.
Over the weekend we had that
back and forth between former
president trump and Mike pence,
which is not new, those lines of
attack.
President trump has been blaming
Mike pence wrongly for the
attacks on January 6th for
years.
He was doing that on that day.
Publicly doing it privately.
But we have now seen vice
president pence ramp up his kind
of positioning as he gets closer
to the presidential race.
He took out a kind of
pro-ukraine position, which
obviously cuts against some of
the Republican electorate.
And now with that gridiron,
replacing Washington, D.C. Where
there was going to be a lot of
media folks there, he ramped up
those attacks Donald Trump and
democracy.
I think this is someone on vice
president pence side who may
have been trying to pick that
fight with Donald Trump, draw
him into the race growing his
own lane, growing his own
position as he heads into 2024.
The race is definitely turning
up.
>> It certainly is.
Part of that with the pence
calculus of why he did that is
now other Republicans are going
to get asked about their view of
January 6th and if trump will be
held accountable that day.
Trump's response, I want to go
back to that for a moment
because I don't think we
focussed on it enough here this
morning which is he is blaming
Mike pence, saying that the
actions he did not take that day
is why they was January 6th.
That's what he told reporters on
the plane to Iowa.
That's the same argument John
Eastman made to pence's counsel
saying this is your boss's fault
because he didn't do what we
wanted him to do.
That's why we're seeing this
level of violence.
>> Exactly.
From that day all until now,
despite all of the evidence
that's come out, despite the
facts, Donald Trump and those
around him, the hardened trump
base, has not changed their
position here.
They still blame Mike pence for
those actions and not sending
the certification back to the
state legislatures, something
pence did not have the authority
to pull off on that day.
And so, when I was just at CPAC,
again a representation of the
hardened, collective trump base,
this is still the line of attack
on pence.
They are defending the rioters
January 6th.
Actually saw folks in shirts
that were really supporting
those people, making sure they
went up to people who talked on
the stage, making sure they
pulled Marjorie Taylor Greene
over to the side.
Making sure that that issue
stayed in the consciousness of
some of those people.
And I think there was an
interesting split screen at CPAC
actually which speaks to this
point from the stage, you did
not really hear election denial
January 6th come up that much.